Speaker 1: All right, let's jump
in to the paternity leave debate.
Now I have to even get into this, I think it's
important to mention that the recent hubbub about
Secretary of Transportation Pete Boudette judge's
paternity leave, it's not even necessarily about
paternity leave. There's a homophobic aspect of
this, which is the feminization of a gay man like
Pete Boudette, judge taking paternity leave, which
really should be for moms. It's really for women.
Has he been learning how to breastfeed? Tucker
Carlson said, feminizing a gay man. So there's
a there's a homophobic aspect to it. That's
one piece of it. There's another piece of it,
which for some people, it's just political
opportunism, which is under Trump. The
Republicans weren't blaming Trump for the supply
shortages that we had early during the pandemic.
Under Trump, Republicans weren't blaming Trump's
Secretary of Transportation, Elaine Chao.
Now, those very same Republicans are blaming Joe
Biden and blaming Pete Budda judge. So for some,
it's political opportunism. But then there's
also an aspect of this which kind of feels
more psychological, either like a my dad wasn't
around when I was little. So there should nobody
should get paternity leave kind of like a
I can't play in the sandbox. I'm going to
poop in it and shut the whole thing down. Or also
kind of a antiquated tropes of it being feminine
to take time off when you've had a kid, right?
So there's a lot of different motivations for
different people. The latest is Joe Rogan weighing
in on this during an interview he did with Bridget
Bridget fettuccini for Tassi. I'm not exactly
sure how her last name is pronounced. I believe
she's a comedian. And again, they get into
this issue of Buddha Judge's paternity leave.
Let's take a listen, and then we'll discuss.
Speaker 5: What's crazy is that Pete booed a judge
during this whole time is on paternity leave.
Speaker 1: And you know what they mean is
during the supply shortages that we're having this
entire time. Pete Budda judges on paternity leave.
Speaker 5: I want to go, Listen, man, I understand
it's hard to raise a child, but isn't that
supposed to be for the person who gave birth?
Speaker 2: It's crazy, yeah. Let's turn now.
Over 70 ships containing five hundred thousand
containers are waiting offshore 500. But he was
Speaker 1: saying, now those ships. Pete
Budda Judge doesn't control those ships,
Pete. But a judge is one guy country of
three hundred and thirty million people.
Even if you believe that it's the Department
of Transportation that controls those ships,
there is a deputy secretary of transportation and
an undersecretary of transportation. The idea that
it's because Pete is holding a baby instead
of a phone, even though he's actually been
participating in meetings anyway, the ships are
stuck. It's it's such a silly, childish idea.
Speaker 2: It's like this negative feedback
loop that is rapidly cycling out of control
that if it continues unabated, will destroy the
global economy. I'm like, That's a nice one to
just right in there. Yeah. So it's complicated.
But I do know the trucking stuff has something to
do with it too, because there is already problems
with truckers. They kind of abandoned California
Speaker 5: when it looked like two years ago.
This is a visualization of the data they used
on watching trucks in. You know, there's just a
couple of ships. This is 2019's last week. Why
are there so many? Because there all. I mean, this
is why. That's why. Yeah, because they're stuck.
Yeah, they're all floating around out here waiting
to find space, to come into there to go wait. And
they can kind of get in there, like you said,
if there's only seven out of hundreds of cranes
emptying them and they're waiting.
Speaker 2: It's not, you know, it's
Speaker 5: nuts and that's why you can't buy toys.
Speaker 2: And it's also
affecting small businesses, you know?
Speaker 1: Okay, so the point here is they're
blaming Pete Boudia judge for this. And isn't it
women that are supposed to take leave when there's
a kid born, not the men? Now, interestingly,
Spotify, for which you know Joe Rogan now
licenses this show, works for Spotify.
You use whatever term you want.
They give six months of
leave, regardless of gender,
which is which is interesting. The other thing
about this, actually, let's look at let's look
at one more clip because I have some other
thoughts, but they're relevant to this next part,
Speaker 2: and I'm questioning
what who do you believe
should pay for something like? I don't know.
Speaker 5: But if I was an employer
and I had a partner for me, I had a guy who
worked for me who wanted to take three months
off because his wife gave birth. I'd be like,
What the fuck are you talking about, Mike?
Speaker 2: And even to support his wife, give
Speaker 5: birth to support his wife? I pay
him for free. Do you understand that this
is kind of most people when this happens,
if they make enough money, the wife will
not work and the father will work right now,
Speaker 1: that might be plausible if the
man makes more money. I have friends where
the wife is a doctor and makes more money.
I have friends where the wife is a lawyer
and make. More money. And it really doesn't
make sense what Joe Rogan is actually saying.
And so even that already is based on a whole. This
is just basically it's a suicide when you assume
you got you guys know the thing. OK, all right.
Speaker 5: And then the wife takes care of
the child. And this is normal. Yeah. And then
Speaker 1: normal. What does that mean? These
are such loaded terms. And unfortunately,
this was not, you know, I think if someone
else was speaking to Joe Rogan about this,
you could say, What do you mean normal? Do
you mean it's historically typical based
on something that started during an era
where often women didn't work at
all and were less educated than men,
which has been completely reversed at this
point in time? It's this very kind of like 1950s
thinking that's not really relevant today.
Speaker 5: The dad provides support when he
comes home. If you're saying that
the man and the woman should both
get like three months off. This is a new thing.
Speaker 1: Yeah, right. New isn't bad now. Like,
that's also fallacious, continuing to
do something the way it used to be done.
Is not an argument, the fact that it used to
be a different way is not actually an argument.
Speaker 2: It's not new in Europe,
Speaker 5: but we're not
in Europe. This is better.
Speaker 1: OK. And so then then we add in this
idea of in Europe, the men are feminized. Their
sissy men here in the United States were manly,
so it's like they're hitting all the different
tropes here. Now I want to introduce a different
kind of question into this. You know, there's
this movement there called men's rights activists.
Now there are people who believe some of
the things men rights activists believe,
and they're not actually men's rights activists.
I think it's important to say they just kind of
gravitate towards the ideology in some areas.
But there's this whole movement which is about
complaining. Women get preferential treatment on
everything in the United States. Men get the shaft
when it comes to divorce. Men get the shaft and
women get preferential treatment when it comes
to police interactions around domestic violence.
Women get preferential treatment and men get the,
you know, all this different stuff. You would
think that they would be saying, Hey, you
know what? This is great. Women have gotten the
preferential treatment on maternity leave at all
or paid maternity leave. Now we're equalizing it.
The men aren't going to get the shaft anymore, but
that's not the perspective of many of those very
same people. So just it's all stereotypical tropes
the Europeans as the sissy, girly men. Real men
don't need time off in the U.S. I'm going to go
to work and then I'll come home and then I'll hold
the baby or whatever. It's just very antiquated
stuff. And then the other thing again, the context
of blaming Pete Bhutta, judge country of 330
million people. The idea that everything depends
on one guy who's home with his kids. These issues
started under Trump. No one blamed Transportation
Secretary under Trump, Elaine Chao. It's pathetic.
Last possible angle? Is it possible that
there are people that are worked up about this
whose dads weren't around when they were kids,
their dads didn't have any paternity leave,
nevermind paid paternity leave, and they're
transferring that into the same type of thing
we're seeing with student loans. Listen, I had to
pay my student loans, so we shouldn't forgive them
for anybody. Listen, my dad wasn't around when
I was a kid, so there shouldn't be paternity
leave now. Is there maybe that psychological
element that's affecting some people's view
on this as well? I'm not talking about Joe
Rogan. I have no idea his family history.
These are general questions that I have.
I'd be curious to hear your thoughts